sur cette nouvelle tentative de la
cedeao qui cette fois met la pression
sur la junte qui a renversé ibrahim
boubacar keïta et qu'elles sont quelle
est votre analyse
cette médiation menée par la cedeao mon
avis je pense que c'est l'aspiration du
pas moins de maliens notamment au niveau
de m5 qui a été le mouvement civil qui a
amené des contestation jusqu'à la chute
du lisible et aux cartes états mais
aussi également de cette branche le
militaire qu' elle ajoute je pense que
la suppression comprendre c'est que la
médiation de la cedeao d'accord
intervention de la cedeao pour reed ou
une solution idoine
la solution la réponse est oui mais avec
l'accompagnement bien sûr est que les
acteurs majeurs reste et bien le peuple
malien
j'ai dis je cela dit je pense que la
cédéao n'a pas cantonner uniquement sur
ce dispositif qu'il est venu avec pas
les appeler à mes vinyles un podestat
peuple malien je pense que ça n'aboutit
pas et ça fait trois quatre et biz dont
côté négociations qui ça n'aboutit pas
et ce sommet donc aujourd'hui ce matin
donc confirme justement cette folie de
l'acide héros qui consiste à avignon
avec des solutions de rouler d'abonnés
et bien sans laisser le temps de pointu
tension majeure entre les acteurs
manière demain je pense que c'est c'est
une redite au niveau de la médiation la
vidéo justement la cedeao demande
justement le transfert immédiat du
pouvoir aux civils et des élections
d'ici 12 mois donc une transition
beaucoup plus courte que celle annoncée
par la junte
même si rien n'est arrêté à l'agent qui
avait annoncé une transition possible de
trois ans par ailleurs on a appris
l'imam mamoud diko qui est une figure
importante de l'opposition qui a mené
aussi la contestation avec le mouvement
m5 affirme aujourd'hui
que les militaires doivent tenir leurs
promesses
il refuse de leur donner carte blanche
donc ça veut dire un peu que l'étau se
resserre là autour de la junte militaire
mais oui quand on essaie de voir
l'évolution des choses depuis 18 les 18
août dernier où le gémeau de dons qu'il
aimerait que l'état a chuté je pense que
ya toi qui sont matures et rentables qui
se soit la négociation et de la
discussion est un intervalle ou des
négociations avec l'acide héros et bien
il y en avoir un il attentif et bien de
la junte a proposé c'est pourtant ça
change vite poids ou plus en sachant
bien que l'acid house et quand on web
elle le savait qu'il y avait aujourd'hui
encore sur le besoin
dimanche à côté de ça il ya la question
posée concernant pas négliger donc la
transition au niveau de la primature
mais aussi au niveau du président donc
la transition
la vidéo propose qu'ils aient tous cette
époque qu'à soi et civils alors que et
de l'âge internet comptait rester dans
la commande également
je pense que ça allait bien ce que je
disais tantôt la cidéral n'a pas l'étude
un acteur majeur
mallié des minis sur cette dernière
question justement on se demande si la
halle
l'ambition de la junte militaire ce
n'est pas de s'éterniser au pouvoir
parce qu on a appris aujourd'hui alors
vous allez peut-être nous confirmer
cette information selon un document
publié sur le site du journal officiel
malien
le chef de la junte a signé aux états
disposerait maintenant de prérogatives
présidentielles
oui j'ai lâché suite est justement un
acte fondamental car il ya trop de
fondamentaux qui constituent un que son
prix ni auditionnée
il complète qui modifient supplée la
condition actuelle du 25 février 1992
autrement dit le jeu institutionnel va
se faire autour non seulement la
constitution en eau mais aussi autour de
l'acte fondamental qui a été adopté par
le sénat ce prix est bien eux
je pense que c'est une façon de faire en
sorte que et bien tous et qui sont
entraînés et qui a des tas de la genèse
vous aurez un film et qu' il ya des
pistes mais pas la voie judiciaire mais
je ne suis ni par la cua des
négociations le politique avec les
livres
bakary traoré on a des petits soucis de
liaison avec vous mais on vous a compris
merci j'entends que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste du mali et du
sahel